Então, eu recebi uma pergunta aqui e vou
aproveitá-la para fazer um vídeo muito
informativo para vocês. Medicamentos
para dormir, será que prestam? Pioram
sono profundo? Existe suplementos que
podem melhorar o sono profundo? Olha, se
você toma remédio para dormir, eu
preciso te contar algo que vai parecer
absurdo à primeira vista, mas fica
comigo aqui. Rivotril, zopidens, Tilox,
Lexotan, até Dramim. Você toma esses
medicamentos achando que está dormindo
melhor, mas na verdade eles estão
destruindo justamente a fase mais
importante do seu sono. Aquela fase que
é responsável pela limpeza do cérebro,
pela regeneração celular, pela liberação
de hormônio do crescimento. Estou
falando do sono profundo, tal do sono de
ondas delta. Vamos aos dados objetivos.
Estudos recentes com polistonografia
mostram que os benensogesipínicos e os
chamados z drugs são zopden, zopiclone,
exopiclone e zaleplon, eles reduzem o
sono de ondas lentas entre 40 e 70%.
Alguns estudos chegam a mostrar redução
de até 73%
no tempo de sono profundo. Isso
significa que você até apaga, fica
inconsciente ali na cama, mas não está
tendo sono reparador. Seu cérebro não
limpa as toxinas pelo sistema linfático.
Seu corpo não libera o hormônio do
crescimento na quantidade certa. Suas
memórias não são consolidadas direito.
Suas células não se regeneram como
deveriam. E aqui que vem uma parte que
muita gente não sabe. Um estudo
britânico de 2014 publicado no BMJ, que
é a British Medical Journal, é uma das
revistas médicas mais respeitadas do
mundo, mostrou algo assustador. O uso
crônico de benzos de azepínicos aumenta
em 51%
o risco de desenvolver aoser.
51%.
Não é pouca coisa. A gente tá falando de
medicamentos que para resolver um
problema hoje criam um problema muito
maior lá na frente. E o pior de tudo é
que quanto mais tempo você usa, mais
dependente fica e menos efeito o remédio
tem. É um ciclo vicioso. Precisa
aumentar a dose para ter o mesmo efeito.
A dependência aumenta e o dano no sono
profundo só piora. Eu vejo isso direto
no consultório. A gente que começou com
meio comprimido de rivotril há 5 anos e
hoje toma dois, três comprimidos por
noite e ainda assim dorme mal. Agora,
antes de você entrar em pânico, deixa eu
te contar a boa notícia. Existem cinco
suplementos com evidência científica
sólida que não apenas substituem esses
medicamentos, mas revertem o dano na
arquitetura do sono. Eu tô falando de
suplementos que aumentam objetivamente o
tempo de sono profundo em
polissonografia. Não é achismo, não é
placebo, são dados concretos. E o melhor
de tudo, esses suplementos não causam
dependência, não alteram a arquitetura
do sono de forma prejudicial e podem ser
usados a longo prazo com total
segurança. Eu vou te dar o protocolo
completo de cada um deles com dose,
timing, mecanismo de ação e evidência
científica. E no final eu vou te mostrar
como fazer a transição dos medicamentos
para os suplementos de forma segura e
sem sofrer com abstinência. Primeiro
suplemento, e presta atenção nisso
porque muita gente erra. Magnésio
treonato, não é qualquer magnésio, tem
que ser o treonato. Se você comprar
magnésio queelado, cloreto, dimalato,
não vai ter o mesmo efeito. O magnésio
trionato é a única forma de magnésio que
de fato atravessa efetivamente a
barreira imatoence encefálica e aumenta
o magnésio dentro do cérebro. A dose é
144 mg
de magnésio elementar na forma de
trionato, que equivale a cerca de 2.000
mg de magnésio elitrionato total, ou
seja, 2 g molécula toda. Essa forma foi
desenvolvida por pesquisadores do MIT,
especificamente para aumentar o magnésio
cerebral. E por que que isso é
importante pro sono? Porque magnésio
cerebral regula receptores NMDA,
são glutamatérgicos
que controlam transição entre estados de
vigília e solo. Um estudo de 2024
publicado no Sleep Medicine mostrou
resultados impressionantes. 80 adultos
com problemas de sono tomaram 1 gama de
magnésio tronato por dia durante 21
dias. Os resultados foram medidos não só
por questionários subjetivos, mas
objetivamente com or ring. O ring,
aquele anel que mede qualidade sono. E
sabe o que aconteceu? Melhora
significativa no score de sono profundo,
no sono rein, né? Aquele sono associado
aos sonhos, né? no tempo de sono leve,
na pontuação de atividade e de prudidão.
Então, nos questionários subjetivos,
melhor no humor ao acordar, na energia,
na produtividade durante o dia, menos
mau humor e mais alerta mental. O time é
importante aqui, você toma 2 horas antes
de dormir, porque o magnésio estreionato
precisa desse tempo para ser absorvido e
chegar ao cérebro. Marcas que funcionam,
magtin é a forma patenteada original no
Brasil. Essential Nutrition.
Vitafor tem inversões confiáveis.
Segundo suplemento, glicina.
Esse aqui é um minoácido que a maioria
dos médicos não conhece o potencial para
sono profundo, mas a ciência é muito
clara. A dose de 3 a 5 g. Sim, gramas
não é miligramas, são doses altas, doses
menores não tem o mesmo efeito. O
mecanismo da glicina é fascinante. Ela
reduz a temperatura corporal central
através de vasos dilatação periférica.
Suas mãos e pés ficam mais quentes, o
núcleo do corpo esfria e isso é um sinal
fisiológico que dispara a entrada em
sono profundo. Além disso, a glicina
inibe neurônios orexinérgicos
no hipotálamo lateral, que são aqueles
que promovem a vigília que te mantém
acordado. Então, estudos japoneses
publicados em revistas de primeira linha
mostraram que 3 g de glicina antes de
dormir aumentou objetivamente o tempo de
sono de ondas lenta na polissonografia.
Então, reduziu a latência para sono
profundo, ou seja, você chega mais
rápido naquela fase restauradora e
melhorou a sensação de restauração ao
acordar. Tem um estudo particularmente
interessante que mostrou que glicina
reverteu os efeitos de privação parcial
do sono. Pessoas que dormiram apenas 5
horas com glicina tiveram performance
cognitiva no dia seguinte equivalente a
quem dormiu 7 horas sem glicina. Foi
impressionante.
O timing é uma hora antes de dormir. A
absorção é rápida, o efeito começa em 30
a 45 minutos. Então, a forma glicina pur
em pó, tem um gosto levemente adocicado,
dissolve fácil na água, tem marcas
nacionais como Essential Nutrition, New
Meilen, Vitafor, eles têm glicina pura
com bom custo benefício. Terceiro
suplemento, apigenina.
Esse é o composto ativo da camomila,
mais isolado em dose efetiva. Você
precisaria tomar 10 a 15 xícaras de chá
de camomila. Vai gostar de camomila
assim na China, né? para chegar na dose
que funcionaria. Então, a dose do
suplemento, a pigenina é 50 mg. O
mecanismo da pigenina é crucial de você
entender. Ela é um ligante seletivo de
receptores benzepínicos,
mas aqui está o pulo do gato sem os
efeitos adversos dos bensepínicos
farmacológicos. Então ela tem ação
ansiolítica, indutora do sono, mas não
altera a arquitetura do sono, não causa
dependência, não leva a tolerância. Um
estudo de 2023 do proego randomizado
mostrou que 50 mg de apigenina
aumentaram significativamente a
quantidade de sono profundo e melhoraram
a arquitetura geral do sono medida por
polissonografia. Então, os participantes
relataram menos despertares noturnos,
uma transição mais suave para o sono. E
tem mais, um review de 2024 publicado no
Fronte e Nutrition posicionou a pigenina
como uma molécula única capaz de
influenciar tanto o envelhecimento
quanto o sono, porque ela inibe uma
proteína chamada CD38, que consome nada
demais, um cofator essencial pra energia
celular. O timing é 30 a 60 minutos
antes de dormir. Onde encontrar a
maioria dos suplementos de apigenina,
vem cápsulas de 50 mg. Marcas importadas
suanson, noods, doublewood, tem boa
disponibilidade. No Brasil ainda é mais
difícil conseguir, mas algumas farmácas
de manipulação podem fazer sob
encomenda. Quarto suplemento, Ltanina.
Esse aminoácido encontrado no chá verde,
mas precisamos em dose isolada para ter
o efeito completo. A dose é de 200 a 400
mg. A dose menor funciona paraa
ansiedade de urna, a maior pro sono. O
mecanismo da litanina é diferente dos
outros. Ela atravessa a barreira
imatocefálica, aumenta os níveis de
gaba, que é um neurotransmissor
calmante, serotonina e dopamina no
cérebro. O efeito interessante que ela
promove ondas alfa cerebrais, aquele
estado de relaxamento alerta sem causar
cedação durante o dia. Porém, a noite
ela facilita a transição pro sono e
melhora a continuidade dele. Uma
metaanálise 2024 publicada no Sleep
Medicine incluiu 19 estudos randomizados
controlados com um total de 897
pessoas. Os resultados foram claros.
Liteanina melhorou significativamente a
latência subjetiva para início do sono,
a disfunção de urna e o score geral de
qualidade de sono. Então, o estudo
piloto de 2024 na Universidade de Sydney
combinou glicina, magnésio e aliteanina
em trabalhadores de turno e os
resultados mostravam melhorias
significativas no início do sono, na
continuidade e no alerta do dia
seguinte. O timing é uma hora antes de
dormir ou pode tomar junto com a
glicina.
Eliteanine é fácil de encontrar. Tem o
Santeanini, que é uma forma patenteada
com mais estudos. Marcas como Life
Extension, Geral, N Foods tem qualidade.
No Brasil Pura Vida, Essential
Nutrition, Bitafor temanina confiável.
Quinto e último suplemento, magnésio
bisglicinato.
Atenção, isso aqui é diferente do
treonato que eu acabei de mencionar.
O trionato age no cérebro direto, de
maneira direta. O bislicinato age mais
periférico. A dose é 400 a 600 mg de
magnésio elementar, que equivale a cerca
de 2.000 a 3.000 mg de magnésio
bisiglicinato total, dependendo da
marca. Por que o bisglicinato é a forma
com melhor absorção intestinal e menor
chance de dar aquela corridinha pro
banheiro que outros tipos de magnésio
causam. O magnésio tá queelado com duas
moléculas de glicina, então você tem um
benefício duplo, magnésio mais glicina.
O mecanismo magnésio é cofator para mais
300 reações enzimáticas, incluindo a
síntese de melatonina a partir da
serotonina. Então, deficiência de
magnésio é muito comum, vocês sabem
disso, é epidêmica. Estudos mostram que
50 a 70% da população tem gestão abaixo
do ideal. Baixo magnésio está associado
a insônia, sono fragmentado, síndrome
das pernas inquietas, aquela coisa chata
de não conseguir parar de mexer as
pernas na cama. Magnésio também regula o
núcleo supraquiasmático, que é o nosso
relógio biológico central, ajudando a
estabilizar o ritmo circadiano e tem
efeito de relaxamento muscular através
do antagonismo competitivo com cálcio
nos canais de cálcio. O timing pode
tomar no jantar ou até 2 horas antes de
dormir. A absorção é mais lenta que o
treonato. E aqui vai uma dica
importante. Dá para combinar magnésio e
tronato com bisglicinato. Não há
problema nenhum em usar as duas formas.
E muitos meus pacientes fazem exatamente
isso. Treonato para efeito cerebral
direto, bisglicinato para repessão de
magnésio corporal total e produção de
melatonina. Marcas tem metagenexics,
forn capsulations, tem magnésio
bisglicinato de alta qualidade do
Brasil. Essential Nutrition, Pura Vida,
for, New Millen, são boas opções. Agora
vem a pergunta que eu sei que você está
fazendo. Como faço a transição do
medicamento pro suplemento? Primeiro
aviso importantíssimo, benzo de
azepínicos não pode ser interrompidos de
uma maneira abrupta de uma hora para
outra. tem risco de sín de abstinência
grave, convulsões, então a transição tem
que ser gradual e dependendo do seu
caso, pode precisar de acompanhamento
mais próximo. O protocolo geral é o
seguinte, passo um, comece os
suplementos antes de mexer no
medicamento. Use o protocolo completo
dos cinco suplementos por duas a três
semanas enquanto mantenha a dose atual
do remédio. Isso estabelece a base e
prepara o terreno. Passo dois, faça a
redução gradual de 10 a 25% da dose do
medicamento a cada duas a 4 semanas. Por
exemplo, se você toma 2 mg de rivotril,
reduz para 1,5 e mantém por duas
semanas. Depois 1 mg mantém duas semanas
e assim por diante. Se você tiver
tomando Zopden, a transição pode ser um
pouco mais rápida, 25% a cada uma ou
duas semanas, porque a dependência
física geralmente é menor que com os
bens de azepínicos. Passo três,
monitore. O ideal é ter dados objetivos.
Se você tem acesso à poliisonografia,
faça uma no início e outra após dois a
três meses. Se não tem, usa os
wearables, né, os equipamentos hoje que
a gente tem em acesso, né? Aí tem o Aur
Ring, tem o UP, tem o Apple Watch. Eles
não vão dar dados exatos, mas são
razoáveis sobre o tempo de sono
profundo. Passo quatro, ajuste conforme
necessário. Se tiver insônia rebote
durante a redução, desacelera o ritmo de
diminuição. Pode adicionar
temporariamente melatonina 0,3
a 1 mg, que é a dose fisiológica. Não,
aquelas megadoses de 10 mg que é para
câncer, pode bagunçar o seu ritmo
cicardano. Casos que exigem mais
cuidado. Uso de benzos de azepínicos por
mais 6 meses em doses altas, histórico
de convulsões, uso de múltiplos
medicamentos psicotrópicos, transtornos
psiquiátricos graves. Nesses casos, a
transição pode levar de 6 meses a um
ano. Uma estratégia que funciona bem é
manter uma dose reduzida do medicamento
apenas para uso de emergência SOS, tipo
uma ou duas vezes por semana. enquanto
você estabelece um novo padrão com
suplementos, depois elimina
completamente. Mas olha só, esse
protocolo de suplementos trata o
sintoma, que é a dificuldade de ter sono
profundo, mas numa abordagem funcional a
gente tem que ir além, né? Tem que
tratar as causas raiz. Por que você não
dorme bem? As razões mais comuns que eu
vejo consultório, cortisol no turno
elevado, inversão do ritmo cicardano do
cortisol, onde o pico está à noite em
vez de manhã. As causas disso são
estresse, acentuado crônico,
desregulação do eixo HPA, hipotálam
ptoitário adrenal, exposição à luz azuis
das telas, refeições tardias com picos
glicêmicos.
A pineia do sono não diagnosticada,
também outra causa extremamente comum,
especialmente homens acima de 40 e
mulheres pós-menopausa.
Você até dorme, mas tem
microdespertários noturnos contínuos,
porque para de respirar. Polissonografia
com oximetria identifica isso.
Deficiências nutricionais múltiplas.
Além do magnésio, tem vitamina D baixa e
tem receptores para regular genes do
ritmo cicadiano. Vitaminas B6 e B12 são
cofatores para síntese melatonina e
neurotransmissores.
Ômega-3, onde o DHA é o componente
estrutural de membranas neuronais e
regula a sinalização serotoninérgica.
Disbiose intestinal inflamação. O eixo
intestino cérebro é real. A microbiota
produz precursores de
neurotransmissores.
Inflamação crônica de baixo grau com
elevação de citocinas próinflamatórias
interfere no sono. LPS de bactérias
granegativas, né, aquele constituinte da
parede, celular das bactérias. Isso
induz a o liquigat, né?
Hiperpermeabilidade intestinal que vai
levar a resposta imune fragmento sono.
Carga tóxica, metais pesados,
micotoxinas, poluentes orgânicos
persistentes interferem em função
mitocondrial na neurotransmissão.
Pacientes com alta carga tóxica
frequentemente tens sono não
restaurador, mesmo domindo hora
suficientes.
regulação hormonal, por exemplo,
progesterona baixa em mulheres,
testosterona baixa em homens, associada
apneia do sono e o sono fragmentado.
Hormônios tiroidianos, onde tanto
hipotiroidismo quanto hipertiroidismo
podem afetar o sono. Então, o protocolo
de suplementos é excelente para melhorar
o sono profundo e fazer a transição
segura de medicamentos. Mais uma
abordagem funcional completa investiga e
trata essas causas subjacentes. Isso
envolve painéis laboratoriais
específicos, cortisol em quatro pontos
ao longo do dia por saliva,
painel de neurotransmissores urinários,
avaliação de microbiota via testes de
feses funcional, metais pesados,
vitaminas e minerais intracelulares,
perfil hormonal completo e envolve
intervenções personalizadas baseadas nos
achados de cada paciente. Recapitulando,
medicamentos para dormir destróem o sono
profundo. de as hipínicos e a chamada Z
Drugs reduzem ondas delta em 40 a 70%,
aumenta o risco de demência longo prazo
e causam dependência. Os cinco
suplementos com evidência para reverter
esse dano e aumentar o sono profundo são
magnésio reionato 144 mg elementar 2
horas antes dormir. Glicina 3 a 5 g 1
hora antes dormir. Apigenina 50 mg 30 a
60 minutos antes de dormir. Eliteanina
200 a 400 mg 1 hora antes de dormir.
Magnésio bisglicinato, 400 a 600 mg
elementar. no jantar ou 2 horas antes de
dormir. Transição gradual dos
medicamentos ao longo de 2 a 6 meses,
dependendo do caso, e investigação
funcional das causas raiz para resolver
o problema de forma definitiva. Se você
conseguir fazer policonografia antes de
começar esse protocolo, depois de dois a
três meses usando os suplementos, você
vai ter dados objetivos do aumento de
tempo de sono profundo. Alguns
laboratórios de sono fazem
polissonografia particular por valores
acessíveis. vale muito a pena para
documentar sua melhora. Deixa nos
comentários aqui qual medicamento você
usa, por quanto tempo você tá usando e
se já tentou algum desses suplementos. E
se se esse vídeo for útil, foi útil para
você, compartilha com alguém que está
preso nessa margilha de remédios para
dormir. Essa informação pode mudar a
vida de muita gente.
Agora saia do vídeo se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade conveniente. O YouTube e o
Conselho de Medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
tenho que simplificar, censurar
dosagens, omitir protocolos
controversos. Na comunidade fechada não
existe filtro. Eu compartilho os exatos
protocolos que eu uso na minha clínica.
Caso e reversão que parecem possíveis,
combinações of label que funcionam,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames. É basicamente ter
acesso ao meu cérebro médico sem
intermediários, lives semanais para
tirar dúvidas, PDF com 47 protocolos
exclusivos, grupo no WhatsApp. Se você
quer ter a visão funcional real, sem
simplificação para as massas, clique em
seja membro. Não é para curiosos, é para
quem quer resultados. Yeah.